Shahji ha
Ali Hamid has mammoth tusks he has to
reassure thousands of his fellow
residents of Assam that they won't be
stateless soon this family was recently
left off the draft National Register of
citizens or NRC it's government list
that identifies long-term residents of
India and excludes those considered
illegal immigrants from Bangladesh
cha-cha ha is frank telling them their
chances of making it onto the finalists
are slim they would have to appeal a
decision against them we don't have
enough money to go to the tribunals my
father is a daily wage labourer our
financial condition isn't good we have a
lot of money worries
Shah Jahan works tirelessly to help
those excluded understand the paperwork
linked to the appeals process it isn't
simply the financial burden that weighs
on these families it is also an
emotional drain to have to prove
something they thought define their
identity if all my ancestors were
Indians how can I be Bangladeshi this is
why I'm so saddened by this it's very
difficult for me to fight these cases in
his effort to help
Shah Jahan has dealt with countless
painful stories the first was in his own
home they thought everything was in
order but 30 out of 33 members of his
family were left off the draft NRC
already they have spent thousands of
rupees to attend hearings
another question that preoccupied those
excluded is what would become of them
cha-cha how wonders if Indian
authorities would create a village of
so-called foreigners make them
second-class citizens or perhaps even
strip the resident rights and only grant
work permits genuine Indian America I am
a genuine Indian my grandfather is
Indian
my father was born here I was born here
why would we accept this there will be
protests uh-huh you merengue critics of
the NRC have said it would heavily
target Bengali speaking Muslims on the
assumption that they are from Bangladesh
a Muslim majority country yet many of
those excluded and draft lists are
migrants from the Indian state of West
Bengal the nationalist BJP government
insists this is a way to oust illegal
Bangladeshi immigrants not genuine and
in this way we need the NRC because many
illegal Bangladeshi intruders have
entered Assam as a result the rights and
identities of the indigenous people of
Assam have been threatened caramel
vanilla though the stories on the ground
show otherwise for many people here and
uphill battle is only just beginning for
those left off of the final list of
citizens this may well be the last
resort foreigner tribunals like this one
are being set up across the state to
feel the peace from those who have been
excluded and they hold the power to
reverse these exclusions people can
ultimately take their matter all the way
to the Supreme Court but such a lengthy
appeals process is challenging you can
get a good lawyer for this they need
resources they need money and as most of
the people belong to the lower strata of
the society for them it will be
Herculean task to gather that resources
and fight that legal battle in homes
across Assam there is only one thing
left to do
wait as the government finalizes the
names of those who deserve to be Indian
a core identity of millions hangs in the
balance
for more let's bring in DW correspondent
nimisha ties fall she travelled to
awesome a few days ago and met with
those most worried about the new NRC let
me show now
two million people have not been
included in that list what are their
biggest concerns for example might they
actually be forced to leave the country
well Michael for now a small amount of
good news for these two million people
is that the government has assured that
until all legal processes are exhausted
until all the appeals process as I
exhausted nobody would be declared a
foreigner nobody would be deported
nobody would be detained now these
people can appeal to water called
foreigner tribunals there are about a
hundred of these in Assam right now just
a hundred make note for two million
people they are planning to add nine
hundred more 200 in the next month
itself but off if the coordinate IP
returns your way there is a course of
reprieve through the High Court and
eventually all the way up to the Supreme
Court but it's also important to note
that the people who have been left off
if they were already left off earlier
from the draft list which is very likely
they've all already gone through a very
expensive appeals process many of those
left out are uneducated and from a poor
economic background so this has already
been a very expensive process for them
and it is very difficult that they would
have the means to appeal all the way to
the Supreme Court the center is
promising some kind of legal aid but it
isn't quite clear exactly how this would
be distributed so Nimisha to just be
just in a brief period of time here very
shortly could the list end up separating
families it sounds like what you're
saying is not immediately yes yes Mitel
not immediately but all the people who
have been left off from the draft it has
been found that there have been many
families where the names of two people
were there but the teams of ten people
were not there one of the families I met
of 33 people 30 people were left off
three were left behind so depending on
what action is taken there is a good
chance that families could be separated
because of this critics say Modi's Hindu
nationalist BJP party is using this
census to target members of the Muslim
minority are these claims true
but Michael government will tell you
that there are Hindu names as well as
Muslim names on this list
however activists and people on the
ground have found that most of the names
are Muslim and Bengali speaking Muslims
because they're more suspected of being
Bangla the issue is from the
neighbouring country the other thing to
keep in mind is that another law that
has been passed in Indian Parliament
says that Hindus have the right to be
brought on to the citizenship lists of
India that they should be granted
citizenships by nature of being Hindu so
there's a chance that even those who are
left off the list and a Hindu might get
the citizenship they are back later so
it's pretty safe to say that this could
end up potentially targeting Muslims
more GWS Nimisha guys fall thank you so
much